القبض على بوتين وتسليمه ده كان عنوان
الدعوه اللي كانت قدام محكمه جنوب افريقيا
العليا في يوليو اللي فات ده 2023 والدعوه
دي كان رافعه رئيس اكبر حزب جنوب افريقيا
معارض ضد رئيس الدوله علشان يلزموا بالقاء
القبض على الرئيس الروسي في اول ما يوصل
لحضور قائمه تنفيذا لقرار الاعتقال الصادر
بحقه من محكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اللي جنوب
افريقيا عضو فيها المهم رئيس جنوب افريقيا
سريرا مافوزه بعت للمحكمه رساله خطيه قال
فيها احنا مش هنقدر نعتقد لان روسيا
بلغتنا ان لو ده حصل هيكون بمثابه اعلان
حربه الظهر واحنا مش هنخاطر بالدخول في
حرب مع روسيا وعلى هذا الاساس ما كانش من
المتوقع ان حد هيقرب من بوتين لو قرر يحضر
قمه بريكس بنفسه لكن في النهايه بوتين ما
حضرش وبعت وزير خارجيته سيرج وعلى الرغم
من غيابه الا ان بوتين كان حاضر من خلال
تصريحاته القويه اللي القاها من الفيديو
وقال فيها ان جهود الغاء الاعتماد على
الدولار في العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين دول
بريكس بتكبر وبتكتسب زخم كبير ووصفها
بانها جهود لا راجعه فيها في الحقيقه
تصريحات بوتين ما كانتش نشاز او خارجه عن
المالوف وده ببساطه لان التحالف او روسيا
احد مؤسسيه هو معني بالاساس بملاحظه هيمنه
امريكا والدولار بتاعها على النظام المالي
والاقتصاد العالمي يعني راسها الصين بتفكر
وبتدرس طول الوقت الوسائل والطرق اللي
ممكن من خلالها يتخلصوا من هيمنه الدولار
الامريكي ويخرجوا من تحت رحمته وفي السياق
ده ظهرت فكره عمله بريكس او العمله
المشتركه للدول الاعضاء في بريكس على غرار
العمله المشتركه لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
اليورو الثلاث اسئله الخطيره بقى دلوقتي
واللي كلنا محتاجين نحاول نعرف اجابتها
الى اي مدى ممكن دول تحالكس تنجح في انشاء
عمله مشتركه اللي هم محتاجينه علشان
يعملوا العمله دي وهل العمله دي ممكن تحدد
الدولار وتقلل الاعتماد العالم عليه زي ما
بوتين وغيره من زعماء بريكس ودول تانيه
كتير بيتمنوا ده اللي هندردش فيه مع بعض
في حلقه النهارده عايز اشكر شركه امانه
برول رعايتها الحلقه دي وهي شركه رائده في
الوطن العربي لاستثمار في الاسواق الماليه
والعربيه والعالميه ومرخصه وموثوقه الشركه
مقرها رئيسي في الامارات ولها اكتر من ست
فروع على مستوى العالم امانه بتقدم لك
اكتر من 5000 منتج استثماري من عملات ودهب
واسهم امريكيه وعملات رقميه واسهم عربيه
زي السوق السعودي والاماراتي وغيرها كل ده
من خلال حساب واحد تقدر تفتح حساب معهم من
الرابط اللي موجود في اسفل الفيديو او
تعليقات فيسبوك انا اشرف ابراهيم المقبل
الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
اللي شايفينه قدام حضراتكم ده هو مبنى
الشرطه الفيدراليه في مدينه كورتيبا
الموجوده في جنوب البرازيل المبنى ده
الرئيس البرازيل الحالي لولاده سيلفا
دخلوا مرتين اتنين بس تقريبا المره الاولى
كانت في 2007 هو جاي يفتتح المبنى بصفته
رئيس البرازيل والمره التانيه كانت في
2018 هو رايح يسلم نفسه للشرطه البرازيليه
كسجين في زنزانه موجوده في الدور الرابع
وده تنفيزا لحكم المحكمه العليا في
البرازيل اللي حكمت على لولا بالسجن لمده
12 سنه وطبعا زي ما انتم عارفين هو ما
كملش المده دي لانه خرج في نوفمبر 2019
والسنه اللي فاتت دخل الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وكسبها اثناء وجوده في السجن كان بيتم
معامله الرئيس لولا معامله مميزه الى حد
كبير وده على اعتبار ان كان وقتها رئيس
سابق وله شعبيه كبيره جدا بين الشعب
البرازيلي ومن مظاهر المعامله المميزه دي
السماح لي انه يعمل مقابله صحفيه مصوره من
داخل مقر احتجازه في مايو موقع انترسبت
الشهير نشر المقابله اللي تم اجرائها من
داخل السجن معلوله المقابله الصحفيه اللي
طولها يقترب من ساعه لولا قال فيها
تصريحات مهمه كتير لكن ابرزها او العينين
لازم تكون عليها في السياقه اللي بنتكلم
فيه هي تصريحاته حوالين براكس الراجل
الجمله مهمه جدا وخطيره جدا جدا
للامريكيين قال ان تحالف بريكس ما تمش
تاسيسه علشان يكون اداه للدفاع وانما
علشان يكون وسيله للهجوم علشان دول
التحالف تقدر تعمل عمله خاصه لها وتبقى
مستقله عن الدولار الامريكي وخلال
استفراده في الحديث حوالينا النقطه دي
الرئيس البرازيلي حكى ان امريكا كانت
خايفه جدا من فكره تاسيس العمله جديده
لدرجه ان الرئيس الامريكي السابق براك
اوباما اتصل عليه في مره وسال انت بتحاول
يا لولا تعمل عمله جديده انت عاوز تعمل
يورو جديد فالولا رد عليه وقال له انا بس
بحاول اتخلص من الدولار انا بحاول اني
اكون مستقل خلونا بقى نقف هنا مع كلام
الرئيس البرازيلي والناقش فكره العمله
المشتركه بين دول براكس واللي نقدر نعتبر
الرئيس البرازيل الحالي لولادا سيلفا هو
اكتر زعيم داخل بريكس متحمس ويمكن مفيش
ادله على ده من تصريحه اللي قاله في
زيارته الاخيره للصين اللي تمت في ابريل
2023 واللي قال فيها بكل وضوح انه بيؤيد
انشاء عمله مشتركه بين دول بريكس تماما زي
ما الاوروبيين عملوا السؤال بقى دلوقتي هل
دول بريكس فعلا تقدر تعمل عمله مشتركه ما
بينها زي اليورو الاوروبي اللي بتستخدمه
النهارده عشرين دوله اوروبيه في البدايه
وقبل ما اجاوبك على السؤال ده خليني اقول
لك انه من خلال نظره سريعه على العالم كله
هنلاحظ ان المبدا السائد هو
دوله واحده عمله واحده من النادر انك
تلاقي دوله فيها اكثر من عمله رسميه ومن
النادر برضو انك تلاقي اكتر من دوله
بيستخدموا نفس العمله واحد من ابرز
الاستثناءات هو اليورو الاوروبي اللي
بينظر له باعتباره انجح تجربه تعاون نقدي
في التاريخ الاوروبيين بيفكروا في مساله
التكامل النقدي ما بينهم من اواخر
الستينات وفي الوقت ده كان الفرنسيين هم
الداعم الاول للاتجاه ده لانهم كانوا
مخنوقين من الهيمنه الامريكيه على النظام
المالي العالمي ولكن برغم كده محاولات
الاوروبيين ما بداتش تاخد طابع جاد الا في
اواخر الثمانينات في يوليو سنه 1988 كان
في اجتماع للمجلس الاوروبي في مدينه
هانوفر الالمانيه في الاجتماع ده واللي
كان برئاسه رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ساعتها المجلس قرر انشاء لجنه لدراسه
الاتحاد الاقتصادي اللجنه دي ضمت في
عضويتها كل اعضاء البنوك المركزيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي السنه اللي وراها
على طول تحديدا في ابريل سنه 1989 اللجنه
المشتركه دي قدمت تقرير ذكرت فيه اهداف
الاتحاد النقد الاوروبي واللي كان من
ضمنها مثلا التحرير الكامل لحركه راس
المال وتكامل الاسواق الماليه الاوروبيه
وقابليه تحويل العملات الاوروبيه بينها
وبين بعضها الى جانب احتمال استبدال عملات
دول الاتحاد بعمله واحده وبحسب التقرير ده
اوروبا ممكن تحقق الاهداف دي على ثلاث
مراحل المرحله الاولى هتمتد من سنه 1990
لسنه 1994 وحتشمل ازاله اي قيود بتعيق
التكامل المالي بين الدول الاعضاء
والمرحله التانيه هتمتد من 1994 ل 1999
والمفروض انها تشمل انشاء معهد النقد
الاوروبي اللي بيهتف لتعزيز التعاون بين
البنوك المركزيه الاوروبيه والتخطيط
للانتقال لليور والمرحله الثالثه والاخيره
اللي بتبدا من 1999 المفروض انها تشهد
تثبيت اسعار صرف عملات دول الاتحاد قدام
اليورو وانتقال الاتحاد الاوروبي لليورو
الخطه دي ما كانتش مجرد كلام لان
الاوروبيين نجحوا بالفعل في تنفي في يونيو
سنه 1998
الاوروبيين اسسوا بنكهم المركز المشترك
اللي هو البنك المركزي الاوروبي اللي بقى
بديل لمعهد النقد الاوروبي وفي واحد
وتلاتين ديسمبر 1998 تم تثبيت اسعار صرف
عملات دول الاتحاد الاوروبي قدام اليورو
وتاني يوم على طول اللي هو اول يوم في سنه
1999 تم اعتماد اليورو ومن اللحظه دي بدا
البنك المركزي الاوروبي الى جانب البنوك
المركزيه للدول الاعضاء في اداره السياسه
النقديه داخل منطقه اليورو الاجراءات دي
كانت بدايه فتره انتقاليه مدتها ثلاث
سنوات تنتهي بطباعه اليورو سواء اوراق
نقديه او عملات معدنيه وسحب العملات
الوطنيه اللي مش هيكون لها لازمه خلاص بعد
ما يتم اعتماد العمله المشتركه من اللحظه
دي الاوروبيين بقى عندهم بنك مركزي مشترك
وعمله مشترك وده انجاز صعب جدا تكراره لان
الاوروبيين علشان يوصلوا للمرحله دي من
التعاون كان يوافقوا على ان كل دوله من
دول منطقه اليورو تتخلى عن سيادتها
النقديه وتسلمها طبعا للمؤسسه الاوروبيه
المشتركه اللي هي حاليا البنك المركزي
الاوروبي بحسب معاهده لشبونه اللي تم
توقيعها في ديسمبر 2007 فمؤسسات الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول منطقه اليورو لهم سياده
مشتركه على اليورو وده حول اليورو لعمله
تتجاوز الدوله البنك المركزي الاوروبي هو
المشرف على السياسه النقديه في دول
المنطقه وعلى نشاط الطباعه ما فيش دوله من
دول اليورو بتطبع اليورو كده بمزاجها
واللي فات ده ياخدنا لشويه اسئله منطقيه
جدا هل دول بيكسل اللي بتفكر في تاسيس
عمله مشتركه عندها الاستعداد لانها تقدم
نفس التضحيات اللي قدمتها دول منطقه
اليورو وتتنازل عن سيادتها النقديه
وتسلمها البنك المركزي مشترك للدول الخمسه
ولو اتفقوا على تاسيس بنك مركزه مشترك يا
ترى البنك ده هيكون مقره في انهي دوله من
خمسه هل الصين والهند وروسيا والب وجنوب
افريقيا عندهم استعداد لالغاء عملاتهم
الوطنيه المعروفه بالارفايف ويستبدلوها
بعمله مشتركه الكلام ده علشان يحصل لازم
يكون في حد ادنى من التوافق السياسي
والاقتصادي بين الدول الخمسه الاعضاء في
بريكس حد يكفي لانهم يتجاوزوا اي خلافات
فيما بينهم زي ما الاوروبيين اللي جمعوا
نفسهم وتجاوزوا خلفاتهم على ارض الواقع
بقى وبعيدا عن الكلام الاعلامي دول
البريكس بينها خلافات كبيره جدا واللي
بيفرقها اكتر من اللي بيجمعها والخلاف
الابرز هو الخلاف الموجود بين اهم عضوين
في التحالف اللي هم الصين والهند الصين
والهند كان بينهم علاقات تاريخيه ممتازه
ولكن لما اشتبكوا مع بعض في الحرب الصينيه
الهنديه واتخانقوا على الحدود سنه 1962
العلاقه بين البلدين اتغيرت للابد بقى في
طول الوقت مناوشات وحاله من انعدام الثقه
المتبادله وتحفز من الجانبين تجاه بعضهم
بسبب مشكله الحدود المشتركه بينهم ولا
طولها بيقترب من 2360 ميل اخر الاشتباكات
الحدوديه بين الهند والصين كانت سنه 2020
النزاع الحدودي ده كان له تاثير واضح على
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين البلديه اكتر من
مره الهند والصين استهدفوا بعض باجراءات
اقتصاديه عقابيه في ضوء الظروف دي خبراء
كتير بيستبعدوا ان اهم بلدين في بريكس
ممكن يتفقوا على تاسيس اتحاد نقدي ما
بينهم ويكون لهم خلاله عمله واحده مشتركه
وبنك مركزي واحد مشترك وده ببساطه لان
الاتحاد النقدي هو اعلى مستوى ممكن من
التعاون يحصل بين اي بلدين في العالم
وبالتالي لما الاتنين مش قادرين يتفقوا
على مساله ابسط زي الحدود فهما بالتاكيد
عن غيرها اعجز والكلام ده قالوا جيم اونيل
مش عارف تعرفه ولا لا بس ده باختصار يا
جماعه هو الراجل اللي صار اصلا مصطلح بيكس
ونشروا في مذكره بحثيه صدرت في 2001 لما
كان شغال في بنك جولد عكس وده سنين من
انعقاد اول قمه لبريكس في 2009 المهم في
تصريحات لمؤخرا مع فنادق تايمز اونيل وصف
فكره العمله المشتركه لدول بريكس بانها
فكره مثيره للسخريه وده لانه شايف ان
الدول الخمسه الاقتصاداتها مختلفه مش
هتقدر تتفق على العمله دي وضرب المثال
طبعا بالخلاف اللي بين الصين والهند اونيل
قال انه من مصلحه الغرب انه يضمن ان الصين
والهند ما يتفقوش مع بعض ابدا لانهم لو
حصل واتفقوا ففي الحاله دي هيمنت الدولار
هتكون على المحك وحكى انه ياما نصح صانع
القرار في الصين بانهم ينسوا خلافاتهم
التاريخيه اللي ملهاش نهايه مع الهنود
ويتفقوا معهم في القضايا الكبرى لانه غير
كده ما حدش هيهتم بهم او هياخدهم على محمل
الجد طالما مش متحدين حاله عدم الاتفاق
الحاصله بين الصين والهند بتقلل بشكل كبير
من فاعليه تحالف براكس وده واضح جدا اثره
في ضعف الروابط التجاريه بين الاعضاء في
التحالف الصين هي الشريك التجاري الرئيسي
لباقي دول ولكن بعيدا عن الصين الدول دي
علاقاتها التجاريه مش متينه بالشكل الكافي
غير كده لا بتربطهم مع بعض اتفاقيات
تجاريه ولا اعفاءات جمركيه ولا اي شيء وده
كان واضح تماما مثلا في الاتفاقيات
الكثيره اللي وقعها مودي ووفده مع الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وادارته في زيارته
نهايه يونيو اللي فات للولايات المتحده في
ظل الظروف دي فكره العمله المشتركه يبدو
انها صعب جدا جدا تتحقق علشان كده
مدير المالي ونائب رئيس بنك التنميه
الجديد اتابع البريكس كان بيتكلم بشكل
واقعي لما طلع قال انه يا جماعه في الوقت
الحالي ما فيش اقتراح لانشاء عمله مشتركه
لدول والوضع ده بالمناسبه مش هيغيره
انضمام الدول السته اللي تم دعوتها
للانضمام للتحالف في اجتماع بريكس الاخير
اللي مش متابع في مصر والسعوديه والامارات
واثيوبيا وايران والارجنتين اتوجهت دعوات
للانضمام للبريكس اعتبارا من اول 2024
انضمام الدول دي اللي من ضمنهم ثلاثه من
اكبر الدول في المنطقه العربيه والشرق
الاوسط في ظل عدم وجود خطط تعاون واضحه
داخل التحالف مش هيغير كتير في واقعه ولا
هيحرك مساله العمله المشتركه لقدام بالعكس
امكانيه الاتفاق على عمله مشتركه هتقل
اكتر لان لو افترضنا ان الدول السته قبلت
الدعوه ووافقت على الانضمام فكل دوله من
الدول دي لها مصالحها وانظمتها الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه الخاصه بها احنا علشان نعمل
اتحاد نقدي في السياق ده فاحنا محتاجين ان
الدول ال11 يتفقوا طبعا وبالاجماع على
التنازل عن سيادتهم على عملتهم ومؤسساتهم
النقديه الوطنيه لصالح عمله مشتركه وبنك
مركزي مشترك عابر للوطنيه والحدود هل ده
ممكن يحصل يعني هل الشيء اللي تحالف بريكس
عجز عن الاتفاق عليه وعدد اعضائه خمس دول
بس ممكن يتفقوا عليه
وعدد اعضائه 11 ده سؤال الحلقه اللي اتمنى
تجاوبونا عليه في التعليقات ما تنسوش
تشوفوا لينك شركه امان تحت الفيديو في
اكتر من 100000 عامل بيثق وبيتعامل معاهم
في النهايه ريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا
لايك وشير واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم
حبايبكم عننا يمكن نستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]